Harry's phone hacking trial began in
London this morning without him and the
judge did not appear to be happy about
that judge had told Harry to be in court
today to be ready to testify if opening
statements ended early well his lawyer
says the Duke of Sussex is coming back
from Los Angeles after yesterday's
birthday of his two-year-old daughter
Lily Ben Harry is not scheduled to take
the stand until tomorrow get this he
will be the first member of the Britain
of British royal family to testify in
court since the 1890s a lawsuit claims
that reporters from the mirror group
newspapers hacked Harry's cell phone
more than a decade ago invading his
privacy the mirror group denies the
hacking